M1: Picking up where I sort of left off in
the last segment, I mentioned that Joe Joe
Biden has been very boring for right wing media.
F3: He just sort of is trying to do the things
he promised. He's not succeeding on all of them.
He's succeeding on some. He's failing on others.
He's mostly liked by Americans. He successfully
did covid stimulus. He's the most popular
president based on initial approval rating
of the last nearly 30 years. And things
are just sort of like going, OK, there's no
major scandal. He even said, you know, the
one of the new narratives has been, why isn't
Joe Biden saying something definitive about
the allegations against Andrew Cuomo? He said last
night in his interview with George Stephanopoulos,
If the allegations against Cuomo are true, then
he should resign. So the right really has no idea
what to do. So they're fabricating scandals. One
such scandal has been the crisis at the border,
which we discussed earlier and we're going to keep
talking about. But before we get to that, they are
also going and going and going on so-called
council culture. Now, we've been covering
like once or twice a week, just kind of a
tracker of how Fox News has now done. Three,
I don't know if we're on week three or even into
week four on Dr. Seuss, which has been a big topic
of obsession for Fox News. And it's become daily
programing on a variety of right wing network
right wing networks, including Fox News.
Check out some of these delusional clips.
Here is someone named Gillian Turner, who's a Fox
News correspondent, trying to make some kind of
impassioned speech about this up ahead.
F7: Plus, cancel culture is spreading like
wildfire. There is now a call for generation
X that is X to lead the charge to save America
from the social media mob. Can they do it on?
F3:
Cancel culture spreading like wildfire. What is
she talking about? And on screen during that clip
was an image of, if you saw it, Mr. Potato
Head, Dr. Seuss, Speedy Gonzalez, Pepé Lupu,
Kermit the Frog and Miss Piggy characters clearly
of foremost importance to the Fox News audience.
As you can imagine. There's also, as I've said
before, something really funny about the Fox News
audience supposedly being all worked up about
literature when a lot of these people haven't
read a book in their lives or since they were
last forced to maybe when they were little kids.
There is some irony there for sure. Here's another
one big dramatic teleprompter read about cancel
culture. This one during this one on screen, you
will see Mr. Potato Head again, Speedy Gonzales
and Pepe Lupu and a few Dr. Seuss book covers
latest apparent victim of the council culture that
saw Dr. Seuss's books pulled from the shelves.
F8: Mr. Potato Head losing his gender
and social media. Critics saying some loony
tune characters are no longer welcome.
F3: This is what it really looks like to have
nothing to talk about now. I don't even know.
So we've talked about the potato head thing. We've
talked about Dr. Seuss. I have no idea about the
controversy involving Speedy Gonzalez and Pepe
Lupu. My guess is that there are some people who
believe that Speedy Gonzalez plays on tropes about
Hispanics and that Pepé Lupu plays on tropes about
French people and smelling. I don't know, like
I mean, I'm guessing that somewhere someone said
something like that. And now Fox News says that
it's a council culture element. And what's really
nuts is that there may even have been more total
coverage of this than of the January 6th riots as
they actually happened by Trump supporters. Like
certainly Fox News has covered the riots, but
in a way that doesn't really tell the story as it
is, which is a bunch of Trump is inspired by Trump
trespassed and committed acts of violence and
and vandalism, then more culture war stuff.
Fox News running stories for 36 hours about the
Grammys, including one story with the headline
Grammy ratings take a massive hit. This
is something they've been doing for years.
When the Oscars come around, they say record low
ratings for the Oscars. And as I've said before,
that kind of makes sense to me. Television
audiences are more fractured than ever. And
the importance of these sort of live events and
one time events, the more alternatives there are,
the more diminished the importance of any one
event is. I haven't watched the Oscars or the
Grammys in a decade. I don't care about it.
But again, Fox News's motivation is always to
sort of gin up these culture war elements. And
then, of course, any time that there is either
an election coming up, we saw this leading up to
twenty eighteen. We saw it again leading up to
2020. If there's an election coming up or. There's
a Democratic president in the White House, you can
count on right wing media talking about immigrant
caravans coming to the border that Democrats don't
care about. Fox also running a headline about
this yesterday saying signs of new caravans
heading to the border. They apparently realized
that they can't really get away with caravans
at the southern border. So they're going with
the softer headline. There are signs of caravans
heading to the southern border. So like maybe in
southern Mexico, they're noticing some people who
are packing up food or something like that.
Then lastly, every single day, every single
day. And we talked about this earlier, so I won't
dwell on it. But it's part of the bigger story.
They've been talking about how Joe Biden hasn't
done a press conference yesterday. It was
fifty five days without a press conference.
The day before it was 50. For four weeks it's
been where are the press conferences? And now
that Joe Biden announced a press conference
for next Thursday, they went on yesterday about
what's suspicious that he's announcing it's
so far ahead of time. So we won't rehash that.
So there's two sides to this. On the one hand,
this stuff really doesn't seem to be affecting Joe
Biden's approval. It's in the very high like 59 to
63. It's been in that range and it's remaining in
that range. And I know it does to a lot of people.
That won't sound very high. If you understand the
range of presidential approval, if you understand
hyper partizanship, if you recall that
Donald Trump, not even for one day,
reached 50 percent approval,
it actually is quite notable.
So the the fake scandals don't seem to be hurting
Biden. On the other hand, what happens when there
is something closer to an actual Biden scandal?
And there. Well, maybe maybe when at some point,
you know, so far there hasn't been, but there
could be. Will they have cried wolf so much that
the real Biden scandal won't be taken any more
seriously than, you know, Dr. Seuss or whatever
the case may be? I don't know the answer,
but we're going to continue following it.